breaking news concerning the chief
executive of the SNP uh the following
statement has been issued on behalf of
Peter Morrell it reads responsibility
for the snp's responses to Media queries
about our membership numbers lies with
me as chief executive while there was no
intent to mislead I accept that this has
been the outcome I have therefore
decided to confirm my intention to step
down as chief executive with immediate
effect I had not planned to confirm this
decision until after the leadership
election however as my future has become
a distraction from the campaign I have
concluded that I should stand down now
so the party can focus fully on issues
about Scotland's future the election
contest is being run by the national
secretary and I have had no goal in it
at any point I'm very proud of what has
been achieved in my time as chief
executive and of the part I have played
in securing the Electoral success that
the party has enjoyed over almost two
decades 14 national election wins is
Testament to the skills of the dedicated
and talented HQ team that I have been
privileged to lead they give their all
to the party and the independence cause
and I thank them for it I have worked
for Independence all my life and will
continue to do so albeit in a different
capacity until it is achieved and I do
firmly believe that Independence is now
closer than ever so just to recap that
there the chief executive of the SNP has
offered his resignation Nara Scotland
correspondent Connor Gillies was earlier
telling us that that was possibly in the
offing and that he was under pressure to
Tender that resignation or face a
confidence and confidence vote in his
leadership there let's bring in uh
Connor Gillis uh tell us more about
about how this has been brought about
Connor
this is an explosive move in the SMP and
a major moment in the independence
movement but also for the Scottish
national party itself Peter Morrell has
been at the Helm of the SMP has been the
chief executive for the SMP since
1999 and in the last few minutes has
tendered his resignation after I think
it's fair to say coming under sustained
and robust scrutiny about that position
he has held for such a long time Peter
Morrow is the husband of Nicholas
sturgeon the outgoing first minister of
Scotland and he has been dealing with a
set of crises over the course of the
last couple of days over the course of
the last couple of weeks there have been
issues specifically around membership
numbers within the SNP which may not
seem dramatic on the face of it however
so the SMP refused to allow the three
candidates vying to replace Nicholas
sturgeon to know exactly how many
members would be voting as part of this
contest refused to tell journalists how
many members would be voting and as well
refused to tell the Scottish public who
ultimately will be dealing with whoever
wins this contest as their first
Minister earlier on this week they bowed
to pressure amid sustained issues around
the Integrity of the leadership process
Ash Wigan Kate Forbes both writing to
Peter Morrow and s p headquarters
calling into question just exactly how
this process was unfolding and within
days those numbers became public and it
painted a bleak picture as to the state
of the SMP at the moment a drop of
around 30 000 members in the last 18
months or so 10 000 members go born in
the space of the last few months after
that Almighty Rao around gender reforms
that first Minister Nicholas sturgeon
had to deal with and of course it puts
the SMP
on a path of splits high profile splits
and this was a party known for its Unity
known for its discipline and that
certainly started to disintegrate over
the course of the last couple of weeks
but ultimately it was the row around
membership numbers along with say this
resignation was a long time coming but
ultimately it's what led to this very
quick demise from Peter Murrell the
chief executive when eventually those
numbers were revealed
but what added to the significant issues
here is that just a number of weeks ago
the head of communications for the
Scottish national party was forced to
issue a rebuttal to a newspaper report
around the loss of 30 000 members we now
know that that journalist was true in
that report that the 30 000 drop and
also that the SMP headquarters had
pushed a narrative to that newspaper to
try and discredit that robust piece of
Journalism and last night the head of
communication said that his position was
untenable and the question at that
moment was who had told the the head of
communications to issue that rebuttal to
that newspaper and ultimately today came
this confirmation that Peter model has
resigned as the smp's chief executive in
that statement he says and let me just
read a part of it he said I had not
planned to confirm this decision until
after the leadership however as my
future has become a distraction from the
campaign I have concluded that I should
stand down now so the party can fully
focus on the issues about Scotland's
future and just ultimately on those
issues around the mess of the head of
communications and how that particular
issue was handled he said while there
was no intent to mislead I accept that
this has been the outcome and I have
therefore decided to confirm my
intention to step down as chief
executive with immediate effect this is
a huge moment for the Scottish national
party Peter Morrow has been in post
since 1999 and with the outgoing
leadership of Nicholas sturgeon as first
Minister her husband Peter model is now
resigning what follows will be a process
to replace Peter model and rebuild what
many would see is lost credibility
within the Scottish national party in
recent weeks